foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ER in America he's more than that he's
right Thompson ESPN senior writer saw
that he did a long well he always does a
deep dive and uh he did a deep dive on
uh Joe Montana and I thought all right
uh you got my attention here Wright
Thompson joining us on the program what
made you decide to do a deep dive into
Joe Montana
I always felt like I didn't know
anything about him and I didn't really
understand
what made him who he was like he just
seemed like one of those guys who uh the
more time a lapse from his playing
career the more of a mystery he seemed
to me I don't know if he seems that way
to other people but I just was curious
what it was like to be and have been Joe
Montana what was Montana's reaction to
you wanting to do a deep dive
I mean
he he came around eventually
yeah Joe doesn't like talking about Joe
no no no he does not uh uh I just sort
of figured if I never went away
eventually he was just gonna have to
deal with the factor
what was that first meeting like that
first conversation like
well you know I I think he was curious
why I wanted to know things about his
psyche as opposed to about what it felt
like to throw the ball to Dwight Clark
uh you know you could sort of see that
like okay what is this uh I mean you
know Joe I'm sure very well I mean he's
leveling uh you know that there is this
sense at least I don't know if you've
ever gotten the sense around him but you
know that that
he is lovely but there are universes
below the surface and so one of the
things that you know I did one interview
with him and had hoped on some level
like hey maybe that'll be enough and
then just kept going back again and
again and again because when you meet
him you do sense that hey this is a guy
who has a really complex and serious
interior life and I would like to know
about that I mean Ronnie Lott one of the
first things he said was like the key to
understanding Joe is that Joe was an
only child and Ronnie Lott was like so
Joe lived much of his childhood in his
own head and uh and then Ronnie looked
at me and goes and he still does
well and I've been around him in Social
settings as well and you would never
know that he was one of the great
quarterbacks of all time there's nothing
about him that exudes that even even his
size you know I think they thought he
was a kicker when he first showed up for
the 49ers because he's so slight but I
also wondered about this and and we have
Tom Brady who is now that guy Joe used
to be that guy now what does Joe think
about where he is in in the uh the you
know Pantheon of quarterbacks now that
Brady has superseded him
oh I mean he hates it
you know I mean like I think uh does he
say he's famous
he said
you know how Joe is he's like but yes
absolutely I mean he uh he watches the
he watches the games he he like the rest
of us wants to know why Pete Carroll
didn't give the ball to Marshawn Lynch
okay you know I mean he was just like
give the damn ball to Marshawn I mean
I I think
I'm gonna spend a decent amount of time
around him and I think it's he's less
jealous of the Rings than he is of
the fact that he gets to watch someone
else sort of live his life that got
ripped from him and also you know these
guys like dominance I mean there's a
story in there about Walmart paid Dan
Marino Joe Montana Johnny Unitas and
John Elway to do an event and they went
out to dinner afterwards any other
laughing and drinking and the check
comes and uh Joe Montana sort of smiles
and is like Whoever has the fewest Rings
pays
laughs
and so they they determined that uh that
Joe had four and that uh Elway has two
and United has one Super Bowl ring but
three NFL championship rings which at
that table counts as four okay and uh
yeah I think Marina drops an F-bomb and
has to reach for the check
uh and so you know these guys like the
dominance I mean you don't get to be Joe
Montana or Johnny Unitas or Sammy Baugh
or Tom Brady or Patrick Mahomes without
wanting to be dominant uh and you know
so I don't think it's much of a surprise
that he doesn't like being knocked off
the Mountaintop uh the thing I found
interesting and you know you know this
so well but
bitterness is such a common Affliction
of once great athletes that it's almost
no it's almost most noteworthy when it's
absent
you know I mean Joe DiMaggio famously
was miserable and so uh and you know in
Montana Noob DiMaggio a little bit and
like I find it such an interesting
Continuum that like that these guys they
seem like names from the past and yet
their lives have something to offer not
just Joe Montana and Tom Brady but
Patrick Mahomes and all these guys
because everywhere these modern
quarterbacks who are going to play on
Sunday are going there are people who
have been
and so you know it's interesting to see
you know Joe working to not be bitter
and to live in the sort of full Majesty
of his life which is really incredible
uh you know his wife Jennifer I'm sure
you've met uh holds no punches when
talking about her very complex man who
she loves very much but is she's like I
think he's the happiest he's ever been
and uh and that's really interesting but
Brady's dominance and blowing past those
four Super Bowl rings and he's the
greatest of all time and it's not even a
debate I mean we're debating you know
Jordan and LeBron and Jordan hadn't
played in decades and he's still holding
that mythical you know place in our
hearts I don't I was just wondering
about that that Joe has sort of been
diminished a little bit here by Tom
Brady like he's in that shadow of Tom
Brady who wanted to be Joe Montana
playing for the Niners growing up
and I mean two things I mean one uh one
of Joe's kids I thought it was a really
Savvy read was just like look you know I
can see the Heartbreak in my dad a
little bit
and that he now wants to talk about
football
where he never wanted to talk about
and you know that there is a sense of
you can feel something running through
your fingers yeah you know uh and but
the other thing that is so interesting
is that
you know
you come
that title oh this is Joe Montana the
greatest who ever did it I mean that
starts to precede you into every room
like rose petals or something you know
and and
there's a morning when it's gone because
you know as you know Joe paid such a
physical price I mean they don't they
literally don't know how many surgeries
he's had both career it's somewhere
between 27 and 35. oh my God and and you
know he he's had before had to sleep in
this velcro back brace and I just love
it because it's like oh Joe Montana is
all of us because his wife is like you
better wear that damn brace and so he
has it on at night and he's trying to
unhook it one microfiber at a time so
that it doesn't make any noise and wake
her up so she gives him crap and makes
them put it back on so I could just see
Joe Montana there in the dark you know
this is his new thrill let me just very
carefully try to get this thing off so
like and so you just love you love that
idea I'll tell you
I came away thinking boy if when I'm 66
this is what my life looks like I will
feel like I did a great job uh one of
the things that happened with the
pandemic is all the Montana kids came
back home
and everybody was working from home and
they were having big family dinners
three or four nights a week you know
their their two grandkids now one on the
way uh Joe takes the oldest
granddaughter to her swim lessons I
guess there's some like fancy Club near
their house in San Francisco I just love
the image of all these San Francisco
moms with the little kids and then Joe
Montana getting in the pool splashing
and uh uh his granddaughter wanted uh to
ride on a cable car and Joe had only
ever done that once and I love it
because he was very sheepish when I was
like when did you do that Joe and he was
like well it was a commercial and it was
me and Tony Bennett and he was singing I
Left My Heart in San Francisco and I'm
like you know that's not normal life
right and so
so they took the little girl out to the
streetcar and uh it wasn't a streetcar
stopped and so the thing wasn't going to
stop and then the conductor or whatever
the noun is of someone who drives a
streetcar sees who it is and Slams on
the brakes and so I just love the idea
that like the great power and joy of
being Joe Montana now is that he can
make a streetcar stop for his
granddaughter and like that must just
seem like such a magic trick to her you
just write Thompson ESPN senior writer
did a deep dive on Joe Montana it's
almost he lost his identity a little bit
where it was firmly cemented he didn't
have to have a sign or arrows pointing
towards him because everybody knew
that's Joe Montana
but then all of a sudden
who who is Joe Montana to these other
people now because Tom Brady did all of
these things Patrick Mahomes is going to
blow by you is like it just I I get it
and he can't go out and be competitive
and play a game and say see I can still
do it and I'm better than Brady was and
I I understand that I understand where
you're kind of lost a little bit there
well and I also think that this is a
complex uh thing that he's lost because
he you know in some ways you know he's
almost like a case study in a
psychological journal and that here was
someone who was the very best in the
world at something and then had the
ability to do the thing they did better
than anyone taken away had to deal with
the just huge hole in their lives
go listen to his Hall of Fame speech
it's unbelievable how honest and naked
it is and people just missed it he talks
about how he felt like the ceremony he
could hear dirt hitting his casket like
he was being buried alive
and that like he was not into the Hall
of Fame weekend like he felt like it was
a funeral and that like who am I
supposed to be now so I think the
greatest of all time was an easy way to
talk about a complex series of losses
and so I mean you know I think if you
really sort of get under the hood of it
yes he's dealing with the loss of that
very simple title but also just with
everything that means I mean what do you
do when you used to be Joe Montana and
you can't do that anymore I mean one of
the things Jennifer says is that she
worries that he thinks the best part of
his life is over
yeah and that they've worked on that for
a long time
you know when you dive into somebody you
do a profile uh you know you unearth all
these great things and I didn't know if
if Joe Unearthed something through all
of this that helps him you know that you
know have some kind of epiphany or
realization through all of it
I don't that's a good question I haven't
heard from Joe uh uh I've heard from uh
some three or four I've heard from his
kids who uh said they learned things and
found it more emotional than they
thought it would be
I mean I imagine when you're Joe Montana
it's not really that big a deal to have
a story written about you do you know
what I mean like like I don't know if he
will approach it as
I mean he's still in his head he's Joe
Montana yeah but you're not dissecting a
game right you're dissecting him so an
outsider is looking at you under a
microscope whereas we used to just look
at you and we would write about the game
you played this is life that you're
analyzing
you know that's a very good question I
wouldn't let me write about me for sure
like
and I I got real problems
uh you know I'm always very very
grateful uh if I gave you Brady or
LeBron
your next one
uh I think uh
one of the things this story is
accidentally is a profile of the next 30
years of Tom Brady's life
and I'm not entirely sure he knows
what's waiting I mean Steve Young Who
you obviously know uh who might be the
most thoughtful retired athlete I've
ever met my whole life I mean just you
know him talking about Montana and
getting emotional because he had front
row seats and now that he's older he
understands he wasn't trying to like
take Joe's job he was trying to kill him
you know for guys who take this as
seriously as they do I think they both
understood they both understand now
Stakes that they couldn't possibly have
understood while they were competing and
you know Steve talked really eloquently
to me about like every great quarterback
wants to write more in the book and you
just can't and you can't let it destroy
your whole life trying to write more in
the book and uh you know talking about
Joe he said you know I think Joe is
surprised that it turned out that what
he wrote In the book wasn't enough and
that it's frustrating because he no
longer has the ability to go add to it
and that if he could he wouldn't abide
this and yet there is no mechanism
for coming back yeah and you know that's
you know Brady yeah they take away your
pen I mean you know yet they take away
the football but your body really takes
you away from that opportunity to write
any more chapters there
in in some ways Joe is lucky in a way
that you know the NFL that Brady played
in is obviously so different one of the
things I did is go back and watch old
games and I don't know if you've done
that recently but I was staggered by the
violence yes like I'd forgotten yes you
think the modern NFL is violent because
it is but it is I mean this was
unbelievable I mean they were you know
the number of times he got hit helmet to
helmet late driven head first into the
ground with Leonard Marshall and LT both
on top of him was just unbelievable and
so his body made a decision for him that
Tom Brady's body did not and so in some
ways Montana got it out
and started building this new life that
in the last 10 years has come to
fruition and you know Brady had to
decide himself I mean you know you know
Joe Montana Joe Montana's a lunatic he
wouldn't have walked away he's a totally
insane person he would have kept trying
to win until they had to literally drag
him off of the field
which is what they did and so in some
ways that's a weird blessing
now he's right Thompson ESPN senior
writer and it's a well as you've come to
expect from right it's uh well done and
you learn more about the person than you
do the athlete because I think that's
really the story and what you said about
Tom Brady doesn't realize it but Tom
Brady should really look at this because
he might be looking at this in 30 years
from now going wait a minute I'm not the
greatest of all time or what happened or
where's my place in history it's great
to talk to you as always I'm glad you're
doing well and uh I appreciate you
joining us as always
thanks Dan it was really great thank you
so much that's right Thompson always
wonderful great reaction every time we
have right Thompson on